SPEAKER: Last week
we established
that CORS is more misunderstood
than full-on Monster.
And today we're
diving a bit deeper.
We'll be learning about
two types of CORS request
and configuration.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As you might remember,
we left our heroes
as they narrowly
avoided a CORS error.
And now they must
learn to differentiate
between the different
types of CORS requests.
There are two types
of CORS request--
simple and preflighted.
A simple request
can be initiated
directly-- that simple.
A preflighted request must send
a preliminary preflight request
to the server to get permission
before the primary request can
proceed.
That is, the client has
to ask and the server
has to give the green light
before the data can be served.
There are several
circumstances under which
request is preflighted.
It uses methods other
than GET, HEAD, or POST.
It uses the POST method
with a content type
other than these types.
Or it sets custom headers.
For example, if
your app uses PUT
to ensure idempotent
requests, this request
would need to be preflighted.
Let's look at what happens
when a browser makes
a simple request
to cloud storage.
The browser adds origin
header to the request.
The origin header contains,
as you might have guessed,
the origin of the
resource seeking to share
the other domain's resources.
Cloud storage compares the
HTTP method of the request,
like GET or POST, and the
value of the origin header
to the methods and origins
information in the target
cloud storage buckets
CORS configuration
to see if there are matches.
If there are, cloud
storage origin includes
the Access-Control-Allow-Origin
header in its response.
The Access-Control-Allow-Origin
header contains the value
of the origin header
from the initial request.
The browser then receives the
response and checks to see
if the
Access-Control-Allow-Origin
value matches the domain
specified in the original
request.
If they do match,
the request succeeds.
If they don't match or if the
Access-Control-Allow-Origin
header is not present in the
response, the request fails.
A preflighted request
performs some additional steps
first before following the
same steps in a simple request.
First, the browser sends an
OPTIONS request containing
the requested
method and requested
headers of the primary request.
The server responds back with
the values of the HTTP methods
and headers allowed by
the targeted resource.
If any of the method or header
values in the preflight request
aren't in the set of
methods and headers allowed
by the targeted resource,
the request fails
and the primary
request isn't sent.
If the method or header
values are included,
the request continues like
a simple CORS request.
Once again, this is a true
byte of the full CORS meal.
So make sure you check
out the documentation
to learn some more.
But let's talk about
how you configure
CORS for Cloud Storage.
Cloud storage allows you
to set CORS configuration
at the bucket level only.
You can set the
CORS configuration
for a bucket using the gsutil
command line tool, the XML-API,
or the JSON-API.
Let's look at setting up CORS
configuration with gsutil.
First, I need a
CORS JSON document.
Here's an example.
This JSON document explicitly
allows cross-origin GET
and POST requests from
origin1.example.com,
but not HEAD.
It may include the
Content-Type response header.
Then I set the CORS
policy of the bucket
to the JSON document.
To remove the CORS
configuration of a bucket,
the gsutil command is the same.
The difference is that the
CORS JSON document is empty.
Now you know a bit more
about CORS, as well as
how to set the CORS
configuration for a cloud
storage bucket.
If you want to know even more
about cloud storage and CORS,
check out the links
in the description.
Don't forget to subscribe.
Give us a like.
And tell us what you want
to learn about Google Cloud
Storage.
Thanks for joining us for this
quick byte of cloud storage.
We'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]